après bien des années de travaux
souterrains et désintéressés de la noué
on trou par hasard une chanson en ord po
inconnu musique du folklore voici le
document authentique et complet il est
intitulé
bord hier au soir jodassin chantait au
Théâtre français de Bordeaux et pour le
remercier de sa chanson qu'il dédia à
Billy le bordelai et au vin de
saint-émilon le Grand Conseil de
ag de Bau après quoi ses bouteilles sous
le bras all au cours de son tour de
champ récolté de nombreux et
sympathiques
[Musique]
bravoant TER avait l'horreur morbide de
ce liquide que l'on appelle de l'eau la
plus mauvaise estant la flotte anglaise
Billy à l'aise nous V del car le pon
von vous donne un cur de lion qu'il
était content le Napoléon il ditly toi
tu me plît pour tout ce que tu as fait
moi je te donne la Bourgogne le bord
[Musique]
car le
bonemi éit le pauvre Garon on lui
a ver
l'au il est dans un
[Musique]
dererouou